[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de kiosque votre magazine culturel alors
au sommaire ce soir de l'humour de la
danse du théâtre du jeune public des
arts de la rue de la musique il y en
aura pour tout les goûts au théâtre
espace Coluche de plaisir son directeur
va nous dévoiler la programmation 240
enfants sur la scène du Théâtre national
de SaintQuentin en Yveline pour
interpréter Hel et Gretel le célèbre
compte de Grim et puis la prochaine
saison de La Ferme de bbat aguill en
cour présenté par Johann Lavabre son
directeur c'est dans la chronique de
Nicolas
[Musique]
Gerbet j'ai parlé trop vite bonsoir
Vincent démon vous êtes desessmon c'est
pas Desmon pardon desessmon autant pour
moi ah je vais pas le faire je vais bien
le faire je l'ai mal fait bonsoir
Vincent desessmont on repart à zéro vous
vous êtes le directeur du théâtre espace
Coluche de plaisir vous êtes venu nous
parler de la la programmation alors je
l'ai dis ça va être très varié il y a à
la fois du du théâtre de la chanson de
l'humour il y a aussi de des arts du
cirque quelle est la couleur culturelle
de votre nouvelle saison c'est justement
tout ce mélange c'est ça c'est
exactement ça en fait la ligne de
programmation a été fixée en entre
madame le Maire et moi il y a 6 ans 7
ans maintenant euh quand je suis arrivé
à plaisir c'est vraiment
éclectisme qualité et populaire sans
être populiste ça c'est très important
voilà grand public en fait on mais
populaire c'est devenu grossier
maintenant donc mais pour moi c'est
vraiment quelque chose ça veut dire
quelque choseul populaire c'est bien ça
veut dire que c'est ouvert au plus grand
nombre comment se fait le le choix des
spectacles est-ce que vous les voyez
tous d'abord peut-être pas ou est-ce que
quasi quasi c'est obligatoire sur des
grandes sur des grands spectacles si on
parle de Patrick fiory si on parle de
Jeff banaclock ou voilà j'ai pas besoin
d'aller voir le spectacle pour savoir
d'abord ils sont pas forcément en tourné
en revanche toutes les pièces de théâtre
je les vois je vais à Avignon de
semaines par an repérer des petites
perles ça on tient beaucoup aux petites
perles c'estd à la fois il y a des
spectacles très grand public très connu
mais il y a aussi de jolies perles que
j'ai la chance de découvrir on va en
parler des fameuses petites petites
perles il y a 29 spectacles en tout qui
sont présentés cette année avec le jeune
public qui a sa place dans votre
programmation complètement complètement
ça c'est vraiment une volonté et de la
ville et puis moi j'adore les enfants en
plus donc c'est vraiment tous les un
mercredi par mois et puis les scolaires
et puis les collèges enfin quand je dis
les scolaires prima maternel collège
lycée Al en démarrant cette r dans l je
m'avais dit c'est la 10e saison on est
une des plus grandes salles dites-le des
ivlines alors merci de me souffler
effectiv le Tex de plaisir c'est
vraiment notre 10e saison c'est voilà le
depuis la réouverture en 2006 c'est donc
voilà on réouvre cette cette nouvelle
saison
10e une des plus grandes salles 900
places beaucoup de public je n'ai pas
les chiffres en tête mais on a une très
belle Jae on est très souvent complet ce
qui à la fois pose d'ailleurs un
problème les gens disent ah ben on
réserve plus chez vous c'est toujours
complet c'est voilà mais habit hab mais
non c'est c'est une salle qui fonctionne
bien le public vient le public est
content et la campagne d'abonnement a
ouvert là déjà depuis une semain il y
une deuxième campagne ce samedi entre
10h et pour ceux qui veulent
effectivement s'abonner voilà on ouvre
exceptionnellement de samedis et puis le
comme vous me le rappeliez tout à
l'heure c'est vous qui me l'avez soufflé
on rouvre au public on ouvre la
billetterie tout public le 8 septembre
le 8 septembre je l'ai dit 29 spectacle
c'est une scène qui est municipal ça va
vous souffrez pas trop des restrictions
budgétaires on sait qu'il y a plusieurs
salles notamment sur SaintQuentin qui
sou non franchement bien sûr qu'on fait
attention bien sûr petite baisse mais
qui s'amortit tout à fait tout à fait on
est obligé de mettre un peu moins de
spectacle il faut faut tout tout monde
doit participer à l'effort hein ça c'est
c'est clair mais en revanche c'est
vraiment une volonté de la Ville de
maintenir une programmation de qualité
et ça j'ai de la chance al et oui vous
avez de la chance à ceux qui vous
entendent certains directeurs de salle
doivent être effectivement se dire il a
bien de la chance Vincent on va pas
détailler évidemment toute la
programmation mais je voudrais quand
même faire quelques quelques arrêts
notamment sur l'ouverture de saison le
spectacle qui sera donné les 25 et 26
septembre Anna carenina donc
l'adaptation évidemment de Tolstoy et
c'est une première en France c'est la
première traduction française au théâtre
c'està-dire que jusqu'ici ça s'est donné
en anglais et là c'est ceris Guy qui a
fait qui a réalisé l'adaptation et qui
est réalise la mise en scène c'est la la
toute première la création chez nous
avant le théâtre 14 à Paris après pour
l'exploitation ça va se passer à à
plaisir les 25 et 26 septembre en
chanson vous avez parlé de Patrick fiory
alors on va pas le présenter il sera
chez vous le 15 octobre il y a Chantal
Goya aussi qui vient et oui ah il faut
tout ah bah oui le 6 février Christophe
William le 30 mars ça c'est des grands
noms et puis aussi il y a ceux peut-être
qu'on connaît moins comme matthie Rosas
vous parliez justement de vos coup de
cœur du H d'Avignon et ben mathieur
Rosas il en fait partie il chante
Barbara tout à fait avec une voix
incroyable on on va l'entendre mais
vraiment moi je je suis un fan de
Barbara quand j'ai vu Avignon qu'un
homme chantait Barbara je dis non ça
c'est c'est pas possible j'y suis allé
parce qu'il faut être curieux j'y suis
allé et j'avais un souvenir il y a
quelques années d'un homme qui chantait
Barbara en imitant Barbara c'est pas
possible lui il interprète et je vous
assure que à la présentation de 16is an
nous avons eu le 17 juin dernier les
gens étaient complètement subjugués la
preuve c'est que les gens réservent
réservent réservent dans leur abonnement
déjà c'est superbe il a une voix
magnifique si vous voulez entendre un
petit extrait de Mathieu Rosas voilà on
vous le
propose
l quand reviendras-tu
lire au moins le
sais-tu que tout le temps qui passe ne
se rattrape guerre que tout le temps
perdu ne se rattrape plus le printemps
s'est enfui depuis longtemps déjà craque
les feuilles mortes brûent les feux de
bois àoir Paris si beau dans cette fin
d'automne soudain je malanguie je rêve
je faonne je tangue je
chavie alors les images sont pas de très
très bonne qualité mais par contre le
son est bon et on entend bien la belle
voix de de Mathieu Rosas qui chante
Barbara avec je sais pas il y a quelque
chose effectivement de très émotif chez
lui qui qui transparaît comme cette
chanteuse sortez les mouchoir hein ah
oui d'émotions ah oui oui c'est vraiment
par que c'est super oui oui c'est
vraiment puisqu'on parle des HES
d'Avignon je voudrais aussi que vous
nous parliez d'une d'un c'est pas de la
musique c'est mangez-le si vous le
voulez oui c'est une pièce de théâtre
avec de la musique quand même c'estas
c'est basé sur un un roman et une
histoire terrible de gantelé en gantelet
s'est inspiré d'un fait divers de la
guerre de 70 un superbe écrivain
gantelet quand on rentre dans ces livres
on les quitte plus hein l'histoire est
vraiment terrible et ce mur en scène
cette pièce de théâtre ils ont russi en
faire quelque chose de décalé ça a été
un grand grand succès d'Avignon OFF 2013
et 2014 et donc nous l'accueillons ça
fait partie de mes coup de cœurs voilà
mes deux perles d'Avignon c'est rosin
c'est Mang voulez bien c'est le cou coup
de cœur de Vincent desessement il y a
beaucoup d'humour aussi également au
programme du Tech il a CLA Vigot le 8
octobre qui est une ancienne avocate qui
est qui est juste super franchement elle
est juste super il y a Beranger cririev
qui est aussi très bien le le 20 mai et
puis il y a Jeff panaclock c'est un
ventriloc pourquoi ce choix parce que
dans une salle de 900 900 places mettre
un ventriloc c'est pas forcément évident
on c'est pas oui mais je peux vous dire
que les réservations on l'a mis hors
abonnement les réservations démarrent le
8 septembre sur notre site internet
parce que l'avantage du site internet
c'est qu'on gagne 14h par rapport à la
billetterie sur place puisque ça ouvre à
0h5 précipitezv la moitié de la salle
sera sur internet et je peux vous dire
que ça sera vendu en une demi-heure
parce que c'est vraiment une vraie et
puis c'est très drôle il est
complètement il est toujours borderline
comme on dit mais jamais dans la dans la
vulgarité c'est on va l'écouter
ave clèbre
jeanmar voici le top 5 des bonnes
raisons de fêter la Saint-Valentin
numéro 5 c'est l'occase de réserver dans
un bon restaurant avec les bougies et le
bon repas c'est sûr que Jacky s'est dit
tiens j'en ai ntin lunch j'espère qu'il
y aura de laavue à volonté merci avec
plaisir numéro 4 la Saint-Valentin c'est
la soirée par excellence pour offrir le
cadeau de l'amour W le cadeau de l'amour
c'est sûr que le NEC il a décidé
d'offrir un autocuser à Martine tiens
chérie je t' offert un autocuseer c'est
pour faire bon petit là et les petites
là je teis dans la gueule je teis dans
le
cul il est for il est moi je vous le
conseille vraiment je P clock c'est
juste super alors il y aura du théâtre
sérieusement avec Claude brassur le 16
janvier dans la colère du tigre
évidemment c'est clémenenceau le tigre
la chanson de l'éléphant avec
Jean-Baptiste Monier l'interprète bien
connu des des choristes et il y aura de
la danse et je voudrais qu'on Sarr juste
quelques instants sur Cendrillon qui
sera présenté par le Malandin balai donc
c'est Thierry Malandin voilà c'est
peut-être un nom qui vous dit quelque
chose pour les téléspectateurs c'est le
le fils de guim Malandin le maire de
trappe mais outre ça c'est c'est surtout
un formidable chégra formable
chorégraphe moi jeavis qui vient assez
peu donc c'est vraiment l'occasion de de
le voir il circu dans le monde entier
tout à fait moi je je l'ai découvert il
y a 25 ans qu voilà quand je dir le TH
quand je dir le thére de draveille en
non j'ai découvert ce qu' faisait à ce
moment-là après c'est vrai que j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à le faire venir là son
Cendrillon je l'ai vu justement attrape
c'était bon voilà c'est c'est encore un
autre un autre coup de cœur ça veut pas
dire que les autres ne sont pas des
coups de cœur mais ça voilà c'est c'est
absolument superbe alors pour se faire
plaisir on va regarder un extrait de de
Cendrillon par le Malandin
balai
voilà Cendrillon par le malandun balai
on pourrait encore parler d'autres
choses d' sendessmon parce que la la
saison est riche du côté du Tech de de
plaisir je voudrais dire deux dates
importante donc rappelez celle de samedi
entre 10h et 16h si vous voulez réserver
vos abonnements et puis l'ouverture de
la billetterie ce sera le 8 septembre et
vous voulez rajouter un tarif à 12 €
exactement nous avons mis ça en place la
saison dernière à savoir que si vous
avez réservé sur Internet et
exclusivement sur Internet 24 heures
avant la date du spectacle en fonction
des places disponibles la tarif unique à
12 € donc pour voir n'importe quel
spectacle n'importe quel spectacle sauf
si c'est complet oubliez 12 € sur Jeff
panaclock par exemple entre autres ou
Fiori ou voilà non mais c'est très
important en tout cas c'est une belle
saison puis si vous me lâchez je vais
être intéressable je vais vous prendre
toute votre émission
merci en tout cas beaucoup Vinc d'être
venu sur le plateau de Kios pour nous
présenter cette saison au théâtre espace
coleluche de plaisir allez une saison
culturelle en chasse une autre nous
poursuivons avec la saison de La Ferme
de bellebas c'est aguille en cours et
Nicolas Gervet a rencontré Johanne
Lavabre son
directeur bonjour aujourd'hui nous
sommes à la ferme de BB exactement et
nous allons rencontrer le directeur
Johan lav voilà c'est maintenant c'est
tout de suite c'est
parti
[Musique]
c'est une saison qui qui propose à nos
spectateurs un voyage un voyage autour
du monde une quarantaine de spectacles
comme ça et on va on va explorer alors à
la fois des spectacles donc anglais
allemand l'Italie l'Espagne mais
également l'Amérique latine la Norvège
la Biélorussie l'Algérie le Japon la
Syrie le bangladesch nina est une petite
fille qui a souvent du mal à
s'endormir un immense oiseau sort de
l'oreiller
serumaza l'oiseau blanc de Madagascar
qui emporte Nina sur ses
ailes
[Musique]
la coloration de la ferme de bbas c'est
avant tout le théâtre même si on va on
va retrouver de la danse et des
spectacles musicaux c'est le théâtre
dans dans son acceptation large il y a
évidemment une une part belle qui est
faite à la marionnette le théâtre je
dirais dans un premier temps est le
théâtre contemporain avec une place très
importante accordée à la création sur 41
spectacles on en a 21 qui sont des
créations je passerai pas pour le
conseil de
guerre fa mais je t'en veux pas ce soir
tu montes en
première mon esqu ma compagnie mon
bataillon en par
ave une des grandes nouveautés de de de
cette saison à la ferme de VEVA c'est
que nous allons accueillir quatre
compagnies pour des résidences longues
on avait l'habitude jusqu'à présent
d'accueillir les compagnies pour des
créations sur des temps assez courts
deux ou trois semaines puis le spectacle
nous allons continuer cela mais parmi
les compagnies en résidence il y en aura
quatre qui resteront en résidence pour 3
ans alors il s'agit de la compagnie
inkaoda dirigée par gofroid Ségal de la
compagnie pavé volubil de la compteuse
pralingepara mais également le dogdon
group d'urée V Dendal et la compagnie
Viva d'Antony
man alors en danse on va on va avoir de
la danse pour le jeune public notamment
le spectacle si ça se trouve les
poissons sont très drôles pour les tout
petits à partir d'un an et demi et puis
la forêt est bourifée un très très joli
spectacle des frères Benaï sur l'univers
du compte
[Musique]
fantastique ce matin une forêt a poussé
dans ma tête il me regarde tous et mon
ventre mon ventre se tort
[Musique]
la Double Inconstance de marivau qui
sera très attendu et un fil à la pâte de
la compagnie Viva en résidence voilà la
célèbre pièce de Féo qui normalement
devrait faire un tabac également les
animales un diptique sur les textes de
jeune Labiche mis en scène par Jean
boileot et nous aurons également la
création d'hôelow par la compagnie Viva
hôel de Shakespeare et la mort de
d'Anton de George
[Musique]
Buchner nous accueillerons la saison
prochaine une une formidable compagnie
de la marionnette qui s'appelle les
anges au plafond avec deux spectacles
alors une création une création très
mystérieuse sur laqu quel je ne peux pas
vous dire grand-chose sinon que ça
mêlera magie nouvelle et marionnette ça
s'appelle R a g e et nous accueillons
cette même compagnie avec les mains de
Camille ou le temps de l'oubli un
spectacle de de marionnette et de
musique qui évoque la vie de Camille
Claudel un spectacle absolument
magnifique teint
d'intimité une pureté égarée un
mouvement comme un envol loin du
monumental on se sent chez soi
si bien qu'en regardant franchement on
ne sait pas qui de l'œuvre ou de nous et
de cher c'est
[Musique]
bouleversant un cycle consacré à la
musique sacrée un cycle qui s'appelle
sacré musique et qui est un voyage on va
avoir à la fois de la musique baroque de
la musique contemporaine et puis de la
musique de différentes traditions
tradition chrétienne tradition juive
avec un concert de musique acidique
également la musique soufie avec W
boissoun à l'auditorium de la batterie
qui chante les poètes souffi du 8e
siècle accompagné au lut c'est une voix
vraiment
[Musique]
admirable
voilà et après la ferme de bbas on
retrouve la ferme du kiosque avec sa
bergère
[Musique]
Catherine comme Yv niic 240 enfants DL
encour de Trapp et de Montini sur la
scène nationale du théâtre de 50 ans en
Yveline pour interpréter hell et Gret le
fruit d'une année de travail dans les
écoles avec des professionnels et au
final un très beau résultat des images
Maxime
[Musique]
leemain dans ch
et il y a 8 mois certains n'avaient
jamais chanté en moins d'une année ses
élèves de trappe dès l'encs où de
Montini se retrouve sur la scène du
Théâtre national de 50 ans en iveline
ils interprètent un opéra rien que cela
on s au début c'est difficile parce que
ils savent rien ils n'ont pas l'habitude
de chanter ils savent pas respirer ils
savent pas se tenir ils n'arrivent pas
se concentrer suffisamment moi je
demande 50 minutes de concentration ou
et et voilà et après ça repart petit à
petit il rentre dans le projet commence
à comprendre l'histoire on fait des
chansons on fait des jeux il faut être
ludique et il faut être très patiente et
il faut aimer les enfants et après ça
marche Gabriel nous apprenait à être
droit à écouter à bien chanter
et surtout et surtout être bien j'ai
ressenti énormément de joie on était
tous heureux tout le monde s'est tout le
monde a applaudi après c'est
[Musique]
magnifique
dismoi donc est c homme sur un
[Musique]
pied
une année de travail donc avec la
maîtrise de trappes et des solistes
professionnels très très lourd mais je
crois la mission accomplie parce qu'en
fait c'est on veut faire vraiment un
travail on veut pousser les enfants le
plus loin possible là nous avons 70 %
d'enfants de quartiers prioritaires des
quartiers de Trab deslancours et en fait
ils s'investissent
énormément
bientôt viendront dans la forêt et là je
les attends je les capturerai et je les
mangerai dans le rôle de la vilaine
sorcière qui capture les deux enfants
morindor comédienne belge elle s'est
dite totalement emballé par le projet
l'opéra c'est pas la culture non plus de
plein de gens donc c'est ça qui est
merveilleux c'est une ambition totale
c'est ça l'intégration l'intégration
c'est exact ça me fait rire on peut dire
tout qu'on
ve l'intégration c'est de prendre des
enfants dans des écoles des enfants don
sait pas la culture l'opéra annsell les
Gretel et cetera le champ classique et
tout le monde va venir voir merci les
enfants retournez voir vos parents et
vous aussi les enfants retournez dans
vos familles et soyez heureux soyez
[Musique]
joyux et de deux autres idées de sortie
musical un opéra en plein air ce sera
samedi soir dans le parc du château de
Buc sera joué donc le Nabucco de Verdi
par la troupe opéra Classica un
spectacle avec l'Orchestre du Théâtre
National roumain de Constanta tarif
entre 20 et 38 € et puis si vous aimez
la clarinette ou si vous êtes curieux de
cet instrument rendez-vous samedi et
dimanche au Conservatoire Régional de
musique de Versailles pour un concours
international l'occasion donc de
découvrir des nouveaux
talents
comme tous les mercredis la chronique
cinéfile et nous commençons par vos avis
de spectateur au micro d'éodim moine
épaulé cette semaine par Anna rimenz
excellent un film extrêmement subtil des
vraiment des acteurs qui jouent
merveilleusement bien et tout est fait
dans la finesse enfin vraiment c'est
très plaisant nous étions les deux dans
la salle et c'est un réel plaisir très
subtil on est sous au niveau presque au
niveau de la la crise d'honneur toujours
on trouve ces femmes mais il a jamais de
de V cris c'est là c'est c'est latant
très subtile c'est par petite touche
c'est un peu impressionniste c'est très
drôle c'est bien c'est c'est c'est assez
fin c'est assez subtil c'est un assez
bon fil c'est un peu trop long et c'est
bien joué mais voilà très bien c'est une
comédie française sympathique dans
lequel François Cluset est tout à fait
dans son rôle super film c'était le
prolongement de la série donc enfin pour
ceux qui ont vu la série c'était super
le film était génial il avait une bonne
ambiance bah c'était parfait en fait
surtout en c'est une histoire entre
potes et pour ceux qui ont vu la série
c'est la suite le final quoi et nous
poursuivons la rubrique avec Gael Pinot
du grenier à celle de trappe pour son
coup de cœur de la
semaine bonjour cette semaine notre coup
de cœur au grenier àel c'est le film
Naruto the last pour la première fois
Naruto arrive sur grand écran en France
c'est la conclusion de la saga ça fait
15 ans que Naruto est sur le petit écran
à la télé et donc pour l'épisode final
pour la fin de l'histoire de Naruto vous
pouvez retrouver au cinéma c'est un film
que l'on propose en version française il
dur 1h52 donc je vous dévoile pas la
l'histoire et la suite pour les les fans
connaissent tous et pour les néophites
vous pouvez très bien découvrir aussi
cet épisode ultime qui pourra peut-être
vous donner envie de voir la la
fabuleuse
[Musique]
saga
il sera proposé pendant la fête du
cinéma notamment qui commence dimanche
28 juin pour aller jusqu'au mercredi
suivant le 1er juillet donc vous
retrouverez évidemment Naruto sur notre
site internet il y a aussi un
questionnaire avec un des lot à gagner
un quiz n'hésitez pas à aller faire un
tour sur notre site donc
w.cinemmagrenieracell.com voilà et puis
gel Pinot l'a évoqué c'est la 31e fête
du cinéma ce sera de ce samedi et
jusqu'au 1er juillet les places seront à
4 € dans toutes les salles l'occasion
évidemment d'en profiter et avant de
nous quitter un coup de projecteur sur
le gecko crew c'est la troupe des trois
danseurs ils sont de Voisins le
bretonneux et de la verrière et il
participe à l'émission go to dance
diffusé ce soir sur TMC une émission
autour de la street dance je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée je vous dis à
la semaine prochaine en dansant bien
[Musique]
sûr
MAK
[Musique]
M